bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de one plus avec une toute nouvelle
version de son téléphone le one + 5
parce que le one + 5 vient de rencontrer
l'univers de la mode avec un one + 5
jean charles de castelbajac bonjour à
tous si vous me connaissez pas je me
tape dessus greu ma chaîne parle de
stratégie youtube et des produits de
fluence qui vous aideront aller plus
loin dans votre visite à halle si vous
voulez toujours être informés des
nouveaux produits et pouvoir améliorer
vos stratégies youtube vous invite à
vous abonner à la chaîne et activer la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune
publication quand l'univers de la mode
rencontre l'univers des smartphones de
la téléphonie mobile ça donne collection
collection c'est la rencontre entre jean
charles de castelbajac qui est un
créateur français reconnus
internationalement et la marque one plus
one depuis sa sortie il ya peu de temps
son one + 5 et on retrouve un envoi de
+5 avec de nouvelles caractéristiques
esthétiques tout ça dans un univers qui
s'appelle collectionne alors
collectionne c'est effectivement un
nouveau design pour le one + 5 avec le
meilleur du one + 5
et tout ça avec l'univers graphique
l'univers esthétique de jean charles de
castelbajac
alors si vous n'êtes pas passionné de
mode c'est pas forcément fait pour vous
si par contre vous êtes passionné de
mode
si vous adorez la fashion week si vous
êtes un grand passionné du travail de
jean charles de castelbajac
très clairement ce smartphone est fait
pour vous avant de parler plus en
profondeur de la nouvelle esthétique de
ce one + et de l'univers qu'on peut
retrouver autour ont déjà commencé par
resituer un petit peu ce one + 5 et vous
dire un peu se tenant le ventre alors se
vendent plus 5 à un écran 5 25 pouces
1080p full hd amoled
il a un double capteur à l'arrière 16
mégapixels grand angle avec une
ouverture en point 7 et 1 20 mégapixels
tel objectif acquis l'ouverture en deux
points 6 8 giga octet de ram et 128
optez de mémoire il a un oxygène os qui
tourne sur un android nougat un
bluetooth 5.0 et ils filent en 4k en 30
images seconde ou alors en full hd en 60
images seconde
il se recharge avec la technologie date
charge one plus qui vous permet de
recharger votre téléphone pour une
journée complète d'utilisation en
seulement 30 minutes de charge
il tourne sous le processeur qualcomm
snapdragon nappe dragonne ce qui chez
moi c'est difficile à prononcer 835 oct
accord d'iliad omap cadencé jusqu'à 2,45
giga hertz il à rester leur d'empreintes
digitales de l'usbc un port jack et une
batterie 3300 milliampères heures voilà
un peu pour la fiche technique du wan
plus cinq mais c'est pas un téléphone
qui va sortir donc si vous connaissez
déjà le one + 5 si vous vous intéressez
à la téléphonie mobile vous connaissez
probablement les caractéristiques
techniques de ce produit a lancé ce qui
est vraiment très nouveau c'est un
design qui est extrêmement élégant comme
je vous le disais collectionne c'est la
rencontre entre one + et jean charles de
castelbajac
il ya un univers qu'on peut tourner ça
donc il ya des sacs cabas et des
tee-shirts des casquettes des holster
c'est vraiment plus dans un univers qui
se veut poétique et chromatique autour
de sept univers d'une puce faut savoir
que jean charles castelbajac cap qui est
extrêmement connectés qui est un très
grand utilisateur d'instagram donc
forcément les smartphones à hupac et
l'idée de cette rencontre entre juan
plus aidé jean charles de castelbajac
c'était vraiment d'arriver à avoir un
produit qui sortent du lot et qui a une
vraie esthétique parce que en règle
générale les smartphones sont beaux vous
avez des deux os en aluminium envers des
grands écrans mais là on arrive dans
tout autre chose avec un jeu créatif un
jeu de couleurs en jeu chromatique et
c'est ça qui est très intéressant si
vous n'êtes pas un féru de mode je pense
que bon ça vous fait ni chaud ni froid
mais si vous êtes faire une mode si vous
adorez ça vous serez probablement très
intéressé par ce nouveau smartphone
alors le produit est vraiment super
élégant très beau le packaging est
extrêmement bien
un réussite si vous aimez l'univers de
serre de castelbajac ce one + 5 vous ne
pouvez pas le manquer à noter qu'il sera
disponible à partir du 2 octobre au
tarif de 559 euros et courant octobre
doivent pouvoir retrouver tous les
accessoires de la gamme collection
voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ce mariage de la mode et
de la téléphonie mobile dites moi ce que
vous en pensez est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait vous vous intéressez
est ce que vous seriez éventuellement
acheteurs de ce mois de plus 5 es ce que
vous avez déjà on voit le plus simple
est ce que vous pensez changé sur ce web
+ 5 jean charles de castelbajac dites
moi tout en commentaire on en discute
quant à moi je vous invite à vous
abonner à machete passeport à toujours
plus de contenu pour vous aider à
réussir votre stratégie youtube et votre
vie digitale si vous avez des questions
je vous invite à me contacter sur
twitter @ monsieur heureux et avec le
hashtag est monsieur nombreux je vous
dis à très bientôt d'ici à portez vous
bien ça lui